So, what do you have on tap for this summer?
Huh?
Do you have any big plans for your summer vacation?
Not really.
I only have a week off.
That's plenty of time to do something fun!
If you add in the two weekends, it's nine whole days!
I guess I didn't look at it that way.
I imagine I will do something.
It'd be nice to get away for a little while.
You're telling me!
I'm heading down to the coast for a few days.
Sounds like you're going to hit the beach.
Yup, but only for a part of it.
I want to visit my cousin in Chicago,...
...so I'm going to fly there and spend a few days with him.
When was the last time you saw him?
It's been over two years now.
I guess it's time for a visit, then!
Definitely!